TREY: WELCOME BACK.
LITTLE OVER A MONTH AGO FOUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
STABBED TO DEATH IN THEIR
OFF-CAMPUS HOME AT
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO, A
MURDER WEAPON HAS NOT BEEN
LOCATED, NO SUSPECT
IDENTIFIED, AND INFORMATION
SLOW.
SOMETIMES IN CONFLICT.
PUBLIC IS GROWING RESTLESS
AND THE FAMILY OF AT LEAST
ONE OF THE VICTIMS IS
FRUSTRATED.
WHERE ARE THE POLICE IN
THEIR INVESTIGATION, WILL
THERE BE AN ARREST.
JOINING US FORMER FBI
SPECIAL AGENT MAUREEN
O'CONNEL THANK YOU, FOR
JOINING US, IS THERE SOME
NEW DEVELOPMENT OR SOMETHING
THAT GIVES YOU HOPE THAT
PROGRESS IS BEING MADE ON
THE DEVELOPING A SUSPECT?
>> WELL, I WAS IN IDAHO LAST
WEEK, I SPOKE TO KAYLEE'S
PARENTS, THEY HAVE BEEN
INFORMED THAT THE
INVESTIGATION IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I REALLY LOVE TO HEAR THAT.
WHILE WE WERE THERE WE TOLD
THEM, HOW.
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
WANT TO GIVE THEM GOOD NEWS
THAT WAS COMFORTING TO THEM
AND AN DIFFICULT SAD
TIME, THERE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE HAPPENING RIGHT THERE,
SOME THINGS ARE SLOWING
THINGS DOWN, FINALS WERE
FRIDAY NIGHT, THE WHOLE TOWN
IS EMPTY TO HAVE AN
IN-PERSON INTERVIEW OR YOU
KNOW TALK WITH SOMEONE
AGAIN, NORMALLY THE COPS
WOULD GO OUT TO THEIR HOUSE
AND BRING THEM IN AND TALK
WITH THEM, BUT THEY HAVE TO
SEND LEADS TO EITHER FBI
OFFICES OR TO LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY WHERE THE KIDS
WENT HOME FOR
HOLIDAYS, A LOT OF THEM HAVE
ALSO TO DO WITH THE FORENSIC
EVIDENCE THEY TOOK INTO
CUSTODY.
THE EVIDENCE WAS ACTUALLY
LAYERED, THAT IS DIFFICULT
TO WORK WITH AND PULL APART
AND PUT INTO ITS OWN BUCKET,
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU SHOE
IMPRESSIONS WITH SNOW AND
DIRT, AND ROCKS AND BLOOD,
ALL HAVE TO BE SEPARATED
OUT.
AND YOU KNOW TESTED.
THERE ARE JUST SO MANY
MOVING PARTS, THEM WORKING
-- GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION MEANT A LOT TO ME.
TREY: ALL RIGHT SPECIAL
AGENT, I KNOW THAT BUREAU
HAS A ROBUST BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCE UNIT.
DOES THE MANNER IN WHICH THE
VICTIMS WERE KILLED TELL YOU
ANYTHING ABOUT THE MOTIVE OR
THE OFFENDER?
>> YES, I HAVE TWO VERY GOOD
FRIENDS THAT ARE RENUMBERED
BEHAVIORAL SCIENTISTS WE
TALK ABOUT CASE WORK.
THEY TOLD ME THAT THE VICTIM
THAT RECEIVED THE MOST
SEVERE WOUND, WOULD BE THE
ONE THAT WAS THE INITIAL
TARGET OF THIS ATTACK THERE
IS ALSO THE CHANCE THAT ONE
OF THE VICTIMS FOUGHT BACK
HARD AND REALLY SAID
SOMETHING TERRIBLE TO OVER
EXCITE THE OFFENDER, THEN HE
GAVE HER THE WORST END OF
THE BRUTAL ATTACK.
TREY: YOU TOUCHED ON
SOMETHING.
I KNOW POLICE WANT TO TELL
THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF
THE VICTIMS AS MUCH AS THEY
CAN, SOMETIMES THEY CANNOT
IT WOULD JEOPARDIZE THE
INVESTIGATION, HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE THAT TENSION
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW THERE IS
NO ONE IN THE WORLD THAT
FEELS LOSS MORE THAN THE
PARENTS AND FAMILY, HOW DO
YOU BALANCE THE TENSIONS.
>> THIS IS A VERY DICEY AND
DELICATE DANCE YOU HAVE TO
DO WITH THEM, YOU LET THEM
KNOW THAT YOUR HEART AND
SOUL ARE IN THIS CASE, YOU
WANT MORE THAN ANYTHING TO
HAVE JUSTICE FOR THEIR
CHILD.
BUT TO DO THAT, THERE IS ALL
KINDS OF THINGS YOU HAVE TO
KEEP QUIET.
THE NATURE OF A PARENT IS TO
BE EMOTIONAL, THAT IS NORMAL
AND EVERYONE EXPECTS THAT,
BUT WHAT YOU ARE EMOTIONAL
YOU HAVE A HARD TIME KEEPS
THINGS CLOSE TO THE VEST,
THAT IS WHERE THE RUB IS,
THAT HAVE WHY HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM,
KEEPING OPEN LINE
COMMUNICATION IS CRUCIAL.
TREY: STACKING FOUR PEOPLE
IS NOT USUALLY A FEDERAL
CRIME, BUT THE FEDS HAVE
RESOURCES, OTHER DEPARTMENTS
DO NOT HAVE, DO YOU HAVE A
SENSE OF HOW INVOLVED THE
FBI IS?
ARE THEY HELPING WHEN ASKED
OR ARE THEY CO-PARTNERS.
>> THE CASE BELONGS TO
MOSCOW POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND FBI HAS A PROGRAM WHERE
IF YOU ARE A LOCAL MUNICIPAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY, YOU
HAVE SOMETHING OUTSIDE OF
YOUR BOUNDS YOU CAN REQUEST
SUPPORT FROM FBI, WE DO IT
ALL OF THE TIME, IT A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM, THINK
THEY ARE VERY INVOLVED WITH
ALL SOCIAL MEDIA
STUFF AND I-T STUFF, THERE
ARE SO MANY OPPORTUNITIES AT
SCHOOLS THAT WENT TO THE
PARTIES THAT ARE COMMENTING
ON REDDIT AND 4 CHAM, WHEN
SOMETHING INTERESTING LIKE
THAT COMES UP AND MAY RING
TRUE OR NOT, THEY HAVE TO DO
A TON OF DIGGING IT JUST
TAKES A LOT OF TIME, TO YOUR
POINT.
TREY: IT WILL BE WORTH IT IF
THE RIGHT PERSON IS FOUND OR
PERSONS, THERE IS A
SUCCESSFUL PROSECUTION.
SPECIAL AGENT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO THE COUNTRY
AND THANK YOU INJURY JOINING
US